the the news that emerged on friday not
that we we were stunned by it but it
puts meat
on the bones that were thrown out there
now 11 days ago by agent mark rogers who
represents russell wilson and mark
rogers identified the teams to which
russell wilson would accept a trade and
of course one of those teams chicago
bears let's refresh our memory from last
week ryan pace the bears gm talking
about their approach to addressing
fairly important position on any nfl
team quarterback
right now for us everything's on the
table in regard to the quarterback
situation and and honestly that includes
players on our current roster that
includes free agency
trade
the draft and a combination of all those
so
we haven't we have a plan in place and
now it's about uh executing that plan
so the plan is in place and it's now
about executing
that plan by the way his hair seems to
like bridge the gap
he could go in the middle and it would
be right just kind of like faces because
he's got the on top and nothing on the
side anyway uh they are executing the
plan the chicago tribune reported on
friday
that plan a
for the chicago bears
top priority
finding a way
to get russell wilson to chicago and
again the bears are one of the four
teams if we had talked about this two
weeks ago we'd be like oh okay fine good
luck bears no wait wait
the bears the raiders the saints the
cowboys those are the four places to
which russell wilson would accept a
trade so the bears are in play chris
and
we got nine days before trades can
officially happen that doesn't mean it
has to happen that day it presumably
well i don't know presumably there's
nothing presumably about any of this
because i've said before you need to
wait until after june 1 to spread the
cap hit between two years otherwise the
seahawks take 39 million this year the
problem is they don't get the benefit of
any draft picks this year if the trade
doesn't happen
before
the draft yeah if it has to wait until
june 2 you don't get the picks unless
they come up with some crazy
kooky separate trade where they send
like a kicker to see uh from seattle
chicago for all those draft picks with
the you know wink wink nod nod we're
gonna trade russell wilson for peanuts
later but i don't think the league would
let that happen no you you got the
timing so the timing is job number one
and job number two is figuring out the
compensation and then job number three
is figuring out how to make it all work
under the salary cap it just to me feels
like too many moving parts too much to
make happen
too much of a cap consequence for the
seahawks it's fun to think about fun to
talk about but man they got some
mountains to climb to get this done i
mean mountains to climb yes but at the
same time i i don't know maybe they're
just sick of it they're ready to get rid
you know get rid of the situation i
think that's the one thing that i just
feel and i think you feel it too
that it's going that way certainly i
mean here we are 10 days later 11 days
later you know it's it's a real thing
we're talking about here that that's
plan a they don't that i don't think
that like gets out in the rumor universe
without that being a real thing like
it's a tangible thing that there's been
conversations
and it's not just like preliminary
there's there's been some more than just
preliminary talks first off i think
chicago is trying to make a move no
matter what you listen to some people
that at least i know in league in the
league and league circles that are kind
of in the know i also think they're in
the waiting for desean watson mode too
they need to make something drastic
happen their defense is really good
their offense has some pieces we know
the offensive line you know is is not
great yeah you know alan robinson can
they resign him or who do they get at
receiver but it's not horrible there's
some other good receivers to fill in
that roster you know there's good tight
end play that they have there running
back situation okay there's work to do
but the one thing that's killed this
regime there in chicago
has been lack of quarterback
from the get-go i mean ever since
mitchell trubisky tripped his feet a
little bit
after the double doink year it's been
whoa we don't have a quarterback how the
hell did we pick mitchell trubisky
before mahomes and watson why were we
the team to do that holy crapola matt
nagy i can't implement my full offense
with this guy in the game all these
issues let's trade for nick foles blah
blah blah that didn't work
they're trying to save their butts and
make the team better
i think they are the one team i look at
to like if there's any that's going to
make a move for watson or wilson and
wilson specifically in this case it
makes sense
you know and they got some good
defensive players that of course seattle
might like there's no doubt about that
but i also look at it like this mike
it's like it it feeds two bellies it
gives nagi a quarterback to go okay i
can run my offense
and then within that
ryan pace he's gonna be able to sit
there and go wait here's a team here's
the quarterback now can your offense go
it takes the pressure off of ryan pace
too to where maybe you know he could
survive who knows so i think there's the
politics of this whole thing that go
into this situation to go with it and i
i think this is still very real and
we'll just see where this goes over the
next few weeks i think a bold move like
this does come with an opportunity to
make the argument that
that they should have time to make it
work especially if they give up a lot to
get russell wilson it it's it's not
something where you've got one year left
just a mere act of
accomplishing that feat of getting
russell wilson could buy them two years
with russell wilson to really make it
work especially if they would have to
wait until after june 1 to get russell
wilson in the program if that's what the
seahawks insist on to get a deal done
and really it's going to be up to the
seahawks look at the seahawks say
the seahawks say
we want to do this deal but there's no
way we can do it before june 1 and take
a 39 million cap charge this year they
know going in that they're not going to
get any draft pick compensation
in
2021 and the bears are sitting there
with the 20th overall pick in the draft
and maybe that could be packaged with
other picks and the seahawks could move
up or just stay put and get their next
quarterback it then
is is up to them to figure out what they
would do with those picks but if they
want to wait until after june 1 then
then they have to wait until 2022 to get
draft pick compensation
for russell wilson i'm looking at
their
salary cap situation player by player on
the spot rack website they'd have to
shed some guys to raise the 39 million
because they're about 5 million under
the cap right now
they would need to come up with about 35
million and just pull it out of the thin
air to find it to offset you know the
russell wilson cap charge
but you know as it stands he's got a 32
million dollar cap hit this year anyway
so you take a 39 million dollar cap hit
if you trade him you only have to come
up with an extra 7 million dollars but
if you get khalil mack as part of the
deal yeah you need to have 17 million to
pay him too so that's why it gets
potentially complicated to come up with
the numbers the cap space to make it
happen but one of the things about the
salary cap if teams are really motivated
to do something they figured it out
gloss over it but they can figure it out
that they have people who are paid
full-time good money to figure it out
we're just kind of you know shooting
from the hip here just looking at things
that would stand out to us but i i have
a feeling they could pull it off either
way they're taking a 39 million charge
it's either all this year or 13 this
year and 26 next year and they can find
a way to make that happen and and
balance that out if they decide that now
is the time to move on from russell
wilson what's your gut tell you i mean
what like seriously because i mean the
seahawks have two choices it's like
hang in there right for what it seems
like one more year with russell wilson
and try to make it work
and okay it's it's pete because it seems
like this is it's either trade now or
there's one more year and it's going to
be a trade it just seems that way it
seems inevitable at this point so with
seattle going to try to make it get you
know one more go
or is pete carroll willing to rip the
band-aid off like we talked about yeah
and make this happen
if you think it's it's done after this
year
you're setting yourself up for a very
dysfunctional year
right it's definitely it's going to
hover over the team yes
every week it's going to be part of
every broadcast it can be part of every
production meeting it's going to be part
of most press conferences any hint any
sign any reason to think
that there's an issue that's going to be
delved into and it puts russell wilson
in a tough spot because
how do you deal with that over and over
and over again well do you put it to bed
once and for all and you know i think
that's what they would have to do if
they decide to go forward this year they
need to come together put together a
great pr plan for how to put this to bed
bill belichick style
one press conference that's it we don't
want to talk about it we don't want to
be asked about it it's already been
discussed that's what you need to be
ready to say anytime it comes up it's
already been discussed it's already been
discussed we discussed that at the
introductory press conference at the
start of training camp that's almost
what they have to do otherwise it will
hover and even if they do that and pull
it off it's still going to hover it's
they're still going to be asked about it
it's still going to be it's going to
fester until it's over no exactly i mean
listen and i don't really care i don't
know how it's going to be on russell
wilson to handle it in my opinion i mean
that's that's where i talk he's the one
that brought this out
you know he's the one that went full
scorched earth on on the seattle
seahawks organization here so you know
it's him that has come out and said he's
not happy seattle can just keep going
talk to russell talk to russell we we
were good we're giving them a you know a
crapload of money and boatloads of it
look i don't know what happened all of a
sudden the super bowl ended and he
decided to attack every aspect of the
football team basically so that's on
russell wilson and how he wants to just
you know just discuss this
whatever and deal with the situation and
that's going to be a pain in the butt
and i don't know if it's in him to
constantly just go
oh we've moved on or i've said what i've
had to say i don't think that's in him i
don't think he's that kind of guy that's
just going to draw you know that line in
the sand and say no you know i'm not
going to talk about it he he likes to
talk he's polite i don't think he's
going to give those type of answers so i
i just feel the more and more we go here
if seattle can just get something
good in return and figure out who's
gonna play quarterback because now
that's the other aspect of this trade
that we haven't hit on you know what's
seattle gonna do here with the chicago
bears
if they do trade russell wilson there
what i mean okay they they might would
they go nick foles and play running ball
run the football do that i don't know he
doesn't seem to fit exactly what shane
cauldron
wants to do outside you know coming from
the rams and all that i don't think
movement is is nick foles game now
there's other options out there whether
that's the tyrod taylors the ryan
fitzpatricks the andy daltons maybe the
seattle would do that but i can't
imagine them being real real successful
with one of those guys at quarterback uh
not with where the way their team is
built right now and that's the thing i
keep coming back to you know they've
gone in on trying to make russell good
the defense is not special the offense
is working
and work you know in progress and the
team's not in a place right now to where
you can just bring some uh
ho-hum average quarterback in there and
think you're gonna get it done they're
right now in a spot where they need that
superstar so i don't know where it goes
sorry what three what three things three
things one first of all
i feel like for russell wilson the
bridge has been crossed and it's just a
matter of getting the plan implemented
between now and the start of training
camp and even though it's been quiet for
the last 11 days and i know number one
there are fans who are in denial about
this and that's okay i would be too i
wouldn't like the idea of russell
leaving there are people in the media
who don't want to have a juicy story
land in their laps because that actually
might require them to work so they act
like it's a non-story so i just because
it's quiet doesn't mean there isn't
something happening because it was quiet
quiet for two weeks until the athletic
story and the comments from mark rogers
boom boom and it all gets dusted off
again so i think there's something there
and i think russell
do it now he wouldn't be talking like he
did no doubt he wasn't second point
point number two it's not shane cauldron
it's shane waldron
although i think shane cauldron is a
cool ass sorry london name i would like
to be known as shane cauldron i just
like the sound of it number three
i've seen others suggest right
that the seahawks can't trade russell
wilson to a team that can't include as
part of the package the quarterback who
is plugging play into the seattle
offense so the bears don't have anybody
that they can trade back at quarterback
so like they can't be the team to which
russell wilson has traded and that's
just i was polite about it yesterday
when i said that's kind of confusing
i'll say now that's ludicrous to suggest
that anyone in the media who would
suggest that you must have the answer at
quarterback that you trade back to the
seahawks doesn't understand how football
works there are other places where they
can get their quarterback there are free
as you were suggesting they could sign
tyrod taylor they could they they could
evaluate any free agent that's out there
exactly they could pursue a trade of any
guy that's out there you don't have to
do it all in one transaction you can
take that 20th overall pick that the
bears send you and you can see how it
falls together there and one other thing
you can do
and i i i and and this look this
happened back in 2017.
who did they bring in for a visit but
not a tryout who was looking for a job
at the time and who were they concerned
about adding to the team at the time
because at the time there were guys in
that locker room that resented russell
wilson that didn't think he was as good
as he thinks he is those guys are now
gone one of them's richard sherman what
if they had added colin kaepernick then
they didn't want to do it because they
they wanted competition at all positions
except starting quarterback hey there's
a guy who's out there
hey
he's he's a year older than russell
wilson
with they saw what he can do they had to
defend against him if you're trying to
find a replacement for russell wilson
would you rather have colin kaepernick
or nick foles
i i in that offense well yeah i mean in
in colin kaepernick's prime him but that
that's gone that's not reality that's
well
but it's it's at least as you under as
you look under rocks that's a rock to
look under sure that's my point i know
you're looking for another quarterback
there's plenty of guys out there there's
guys you don't have to have it as part
of the trade that's my point the idea
that it has to be part of the trade is
ludicrous to me no they're it you're
right and you know i don't can you work
out a three-way trade is there something
like that there's those possibilities
hey you talked about the number 20 pick
i don't know if there's going to be
anybody there you know worthwhile for
them right now
you know at that i don't know what do
you think of your six guys right because
last week you suggested all six of them
are going to possibly go in the first
yeah i think the five for sure i think
still be there at 20. well i think trey
lance is the guy that'll be out of the
first round so when i look at the first
three i think all first three are top
ten picks that's for sure when you just
talk about wilson lawrence and mac jones
i think they're all top ten picks like
we discussed
mack jones to me
is clearly a better prospect than tool
was coming out and he was the number
five pick of the draft
and i'm not saying that to put down two
i'm just saying mac jones is a top ten
pick i think kellen mon is in that next
group right to where maybe he could be
there around 20. you know again i'm not
kellen mann's first round talent to me
i'm not backing off of that what i see
on film and everything i see it it pops
off i don't know what there is not to
like about the guy you know all these
people who want to jump on johnny
manziel and him coming out of texas a m
i want to go this guy is like like yours
better than him his game translates
better than the nfl so he or justin
field our fields justin fields could be
there i think those are the two guys you
would look at right and hey
they could make it work with either one
if they wanted to play that type of
football justin fields you could really
play
you know run the quarterback cam newton
what we saw a little bit with the new
england patriots type offense because
he's that kind of physical specimen
so you could do that i mean yeah i mean
maybe but here's like the other thing
you know yeah the quarterback thing
you're right they can figure that out
however they want to if they really want
to just get this done and not deal with
russell wilson and get it over with
they'll figure it out and this is a team
that i don't think is all scared
necessarily to play without the
quarterback i i don't think they are you
know just their history would tell me
that they think they can do it other
ways playing that game but here's the
other thing too mike that i just bring
up like if you're the bears right and
your ownership and all of that
and you know that this could be it for
pace and nagi
are you gonna give them the green light
to just go
trade whatever future assets you want so
we can screw over the next regime that
comes here just in case too that's
another aspect i think of this as well
where at least if i'm ownership or in
charge there in chicago i i'm keeping a
close eye on that to go wait wait you
know i don't know i'm not sure i don't
want to just totally you know open up
the cupboard here and have nothing to
just go all in to save ryan pace and
matinee as we go forward too and i think
that's another aspect that that needs to
be tossed around a little bit
here's the question yeah here's the
question right is ted phillips who's
been the ceo of that team since 1999 is
he
in danger along with negan pace because
any time
that the job security comes up the
coaching gm now i mentioned ted phillips
because he's in one of these jobs where
you get a pass yeah you are
part of the football operation you're
responsible for hiring the gm and the
coach
but
you aren't accountable like they are
when things go sideways what have the
bears really done since ted phillips
became the team ceo so if he believes
that he'd be part of a house cleaning
yeah and he still has influence over
george mccaskey the chairman of the team
and i assume that phillips does or he
wouldn't be there then phillips can
persuade george that let's do this
russell wilson thing and of course when
you're talking about that level of
communication it's far more subtle it's
far more nuanced but i think that that
phillips if he's in the pace
naggy
yeah i may be
on the endangered species list
and i may go with them
then then he can try to push it through
if he is safe on the other side of the
get fired firewall
that's when phillips could say well we
know what you're really trying to do
here you're just trying to to delay the
hatchet by a couple of years by making
this big splash for russell wilson but
the other side of it chris
they haven't had a great quarterback no
i know in decades and they tried to get
jake well they did get jay cutler they
hoped he was going to be great he did
set some franchise records what did he
ever really do right they still haven't
had that great quarterback since sid
luckman
some would argue that russell wilson
walks through the door as the greatest
quarterback in the history of the bears
organization of course he'd have to
prove it in a bear's uniform and uh so i
look i can understand why the bears
would want to do it how often is it that
a franchise quarterback shortlist one of
the best quarterbacks in football wants
to play for you when that happens yeah i
think you over to yourself to see if you
can make it happen no no doubt i don't
disagree with that at one bit certainly
and it is a
you know as far as just fanfare
propaganda whatever you're right chicago
is going to be so excited you know the
the assets that go out the door and
things like that are just gonna be swept
under the rug because they're gonna go
man we got russell wilson we got a guy
here finally all these years we've been
watching damn brett favre and aaron
rodgers and green bay's had all this
great luck at quarterback and everything
like that and here they got a guy like
that uh i mean that would be huge news
yes and i i still think well keep our
eye on this because i really think chris
i got a quiz for you yeah i got a quiz
for you got a question for you over
under style over under style yeah
number of quarterbacks drafted by
the seahawks
with pete carroll and john schneider in
seattle the over under is 2.5
oh you're saying so how many have they
drafted uh you're a 2.5 since they've
been there let's see so i'm just trying
to think off the top of my head here
man i feel like he's the only one
they've drafted
am i correct
no there's one more alex mcguff oh 2018
seventh round i wouldn't agree that's
the only guy that's been drafted since
russell wilson at quarterback he's also
on the roster along with danny etling
and geno smith
safe to say none of those three guys
will be the starting quarterback in the
event that russell wilson has traded but
really isn't that odd that pete carroll
has insulated russell wilson from any
type of real competition
that that this is the coach who preaches
compete compete compete ones against
ones we're always competing we're always
looking for the best except at the qb
one position and they're gonna pay for
that because they don't have a guy that
you could turn to and say we'll just
bump him up you know how many times do
we see a guy get get injured and well we
have a guy in our system he's ready to
go we've been grooming him they don't
have anybody they've been grooming no so
that that exacerbates the problem for
them as they try to find a replacement
if they end up having to find a
replacement if russell wilson gets
traded it's not going to be easy but
it's not impossible and again it doesn't
have to come from the bears it's not
like they're going to sign mitchell
trubisky and send him to seattle as part
of the since look seattle could sign mr
trubisky he's going to be a free agent
you mentioned cam newton they could sign
cam newton for crying out loud if they
wanted there's lots of things and
they've seen they've seen cam newton at
his best because they've faced him in
the playoffs at his best yeah i i don't
think that's a crazy thought either
again that goes into
you know i think that fits
a little bit of way maybe pete carroll
would want to play football to a degree
run the ball control the clock
everything you saw new england do with
cam cam newton last year and of course
yeah cam had some flaws throwing the
football he'll fix them he's gonna get
back i don't doubt that it was a weird
year last year for everybody that thinks
like you're gonna continue to see cam
newton like miss 10 yard outs on the
left and the right like that it's not to
happen he still can make things happen
so yes there's options out there it's
just about do they want to take that cap
hit like you're talking about do they
want to be done with it which i really
feel like they do because i just don't
think schneider and pete carroll the
type that want to deal with this type of
crap i never have thought it and then
you know just we go back to the rumors
back when his contract was coming up and
the things you heard there i just don't
know if there was ever a full-fledged
we're all in love affair for russell
wilson i think there was reluctancy to
pay him there's obviously reluctancy to
just go all in on him on the offensive
side of the ball i mean we know that
that's why we're here and talking about
this right now
and i you know i just i won't be shocked
here sometime in the next five or six
week all of a sudden we just wake up one
morning and he's gone and he's out of
town
two quick points before we pivot one
when he signed his last contract it paid
at the time the highest average that any
quarterback or any players ever received
in the nfl 35 million dollars remember
after all that stuff with jimmy fallon
and they planted the question about do
you do you want to be the highest paid
player in nfl history like jimmy fallon
is paying attention to this
good question jimmy good that's a great
question jimmy thank you for reading it
off the card that we gave you before the
show i was told at the time
that was the last contract russell
wilson was signed with the seahawks
yeah that probably pissed them off right
there closer and closer too yeah and uh
um also number three russell wilson's
preferred number although he wore 16 at
nc state and wisconsin three has been
his identity since 2012 retired by the
bears bronco nagurski another one of
these issues that we may have although
george mccaskey the chairman of the
bears said six seven years ago
that they may have to start unretiring
numbers they have 14 of them and if they
do the first one would be number seven
because that's george hales number the
rare confluence of family members who
can give their blessing and football
team who can issue the numbers the halas
family can say number seven is coming
back maybe that would be russell
wilson's number put him in number seven
the george halas number in chicago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports